[Music]
go to the planet typhon oh great thanks
to this recap we can recall how
unhelpful ahsoka's been in this entire
series and is only there so she can set
herself up a spin-off it's exactly like
nicki minaj showing up to steal kanye's
monster track with her verse knowing
that she's just creating pub for the
eventual album pink friday yep i just
compared to sokatano to nicki minaj
there aren't many jedi left that's okay
with advanced technology no jedi can
ever really die and in a pinch we can
sort of copy paste their face on a new
body for maximum impact not this show
would ever do anything like that why is
boba fett even shooting at them right
now they definitely want dr pershing
alive so what if they accidentally
destroy him and his ship i'll tell you
what would happen the creation of the
greatest gif ever of boba fett
performing an epic face palm do you ever
wonder what massive light source
illuminates the spaceship porn yeah me
either comms are down i'm sorry sir
we've established in this series that
everyone speaks an american accent for
some reason i think you're looking for
the jj abrams trilogy it's right down
the hall
so the ion cannon wiped out some comms
but not the very specific comms needed
to hear this announcement neat i don't
have a death wish do you a surprising
admission for a person who in mere
moments will brutally goad xena with
vile threats until she blasts him
is he shocked horrified impressed horny
the world may never know wait wait i
know this one two mandalorians walk into
a bar the bartender turns to the first
one and says why the long face and the
second one says don't test us and then
the bartender says you mean man don't
test us
and then they kill him also character
walks into a saloon and everyone stops
turns and stares cliche oh hey it's two
of the most famous and dangerous
mandalorian warriors in the galaxy and
amanda was able to locate them in record
time despite having no clue that they
existed until a few episodes ago they
took the child who
moth gideon
you'll never find him bo katan
rightfully states that finding grogu
will be impossible and then the scene
goes off-roading into a bounty hunter
pissing match for a few minutes then
when we finally veer back to the plot
mando reveals he has moff's coordinates
and my point is why doesn't he say this
here when it's relevant to their
immediate conversation you won't find
him actually i have the coordinates
let's go and seen save it
so
it's a go so why throw the bow no to
mando in the flow show you are a
disgrace to your armor the heck is a bo
katan's ass about boba fett just a few
episodes ago she was all kumbaya about
there being different types of
mandalorians but she's going hard at
boba for no reason other than his voice
and even though stormtrooper clones were
based off django ain't none of them
sound anything like him
mandalorians have been in exile from our
home world for far too long expositional
motivation exposivation i will kill them
off and retake what is rightfully mine
and that is all you need to know or not
know for now there's plenty of time to
cover any incredibly specific details
about the importance of how i need to
kill him and take the weapon but i think
reckless secrecy is a supremely good
idea for right now what's up with
pershing's indoor sunglasses here are
those prescription or is he just corey
harding everyone an attempt to look cool
these are a third generation design they
are no longer suits they didn't even
threaten pershing or even ask for his
opinion this motor scuffer is just
spouting off about the ship's logistics
like he's under some sort of truth serum
or something where they bivv whacked
good lord that is a really personal
question have you no shame koska fennec
dune myself disembark with maximum
initiative phew good to know bo katan
setting her phaser to maximum initiative
i'd hate to see how this plan would go
down if she dialed that back to like i
don't know six and a half
here
take his code cylinder and seal off
their holding bay no need to talk about
which buttons to press on the panel to
ensure that the holding bay doors
actually close the power of the
doohickey device is all you need
[Music]
requesting emergency docking they're
doing a good job pretending it's an
emergency but the amps also know that
this is the shuttle that's bringing back
the super important pershing so how do
they not immediately realize something's
up when a female voice is coming from a
ship that was previously piloted by two
dudes somewhere there's a reddit thread
begging to see how the tie fighters are
launched this end's for you and there
goes boba fett i understand he's not
part of the ship takeover but don't you
think the plant could have included him
doing a bit more to help oh yeah my
favorite parts of star wars properties
are the extended blurry sequences of the
protagonists easily offing these super
killable stormtroopers
dude activating the dim droids also
activates some of the gnarliest
industrial music i've heard since nine
inch nails pretty hate machine someone
said this scene needs charging station
wiggle tubes that spew snow and fog
those people were wrong
she totally kicked that dude's ass
before actually killing him what was the
point fenix a cold mudder scuffer man
are we really rooting for her my gun
holy moly when did blaster start jamming
and running out of ammo like it did in
the last episode those things never seem
to malfunction in the hands of
stormtroopers except for you know when
they try to aim at something unwelcome
dimdroid flareups if the dim dirts got
this close to breaking the glass don't
you think the sudden vacuum of space
would be enough to finish the job and
suck mando out along with them
this universe has more nonsensical curse
words than the forking good place okay
look an all-female takeover of this ship
is the perfect authentic antithesis to
the bull shirt that marvel stuffed down
our throats and end game and it deserves
to send off
great question in considering the
importance of your quest you should
probably leave the bridge to go look for
him i'd start in the one place you know
he holds a super important tiny prisoner
but hey you can just hang out here until
the plot complexes things quite a bit
for you later what good do shackles do
for this padawan's jedi abilities sure
you see jedi use their hands when they
force push things around and stuff but
he can do all that with his mind right
are the hand movements essential like
james mcavoy touching his temple to read
minds in the newer x-men movies drop the
blaster but not the best car pokey pole
the jet pack or flame thrower those are
okay where is this going well given the
recent announcements in the post-credits
stinger i've heard is at the end of this
episode i'm going to say
security one three seven uh divided by
pi about 47 spin-offs from the two
seasons of this show i'm guessing that
bokeh tan and her boarding party have
arrived at the bridge you know this
scene would be far more interesting if
he hadn't just said assume that i know
everything but now he's all i'm guessing
so do you know anything or not are you
scary you see she wants
this i guess i'm kind of immune to the
villain exposits vital information right
before the final flight cliche at this
point but when it's information that we
already know it deserves an extra five
sins whoever wields this sword
has the right to lay claim to the
mandalorian throne well that's just dumb
what if a wampa picked it up and swung
it around does that mean the wampa would
lead the mandalorians is this another
spin-off a young wampa wins the dark
saber in battle but this time it's a
dance battle womp the yard coming to
disney plus fall 2021 man gideon just
keeps whacking away despite seeing no
damage being done to mando's suit he
knows that's best car right poketon's
sole mission depends on her defeating
gideon so why is she staring out the
window like she's looking for the next
galactic gas station for a quick piss
and greasy snack why don't you kill him
now and take it is moth getting an
empire loyalist or a merry prankster
seems like he's more amused that he just
got his ass handed to him instead of
figuring out a way to turn the tides in
battle it must be won
in battle rules oh no the mark 10s have
invaded the ship this is terrible news
how will they ever do
you're about to face off with the dark
troopers you said dem droid's wrong
you had your hands full with one really
it took amanda less than a freaking
minute to take care of that one and now
he knows how they work here's an idea
grab a cylinder pull a lever and
jettison them into space again but this
time aim the big starship guns at them
boom bam done i am so good at star wars
bad guy is suddenly armed and unwatched
despite being incredibly dangerous and
the focus of all the heroes hatred up
until now cliche mando has his blaster
out here even though he knows the only
thing that worked last time was the best
car spear seriously i know we're all
excited about this finale but there's a
lot of weird [ __ ] near the end of this
sucker
the sound of this alarm seems to wait is
that an x-wing that's an x-wing what is
groga sensing who's on the screen who's
in the robe is it they have a lightsaber
that is a lightsaber that is a saber of
light the light is sabering that is a
green light
saber look at him go oh this is in the
force push oh and the spin oh he cut
that thing right in half what is he
the gloved hand
he has a gloved hand the force pushed
the leg chop he jumped off his head he's
going into the elevator he's coming up
why is this elevator ride taking forever
open the elevator i need to see
show me here it comes
yes get him get him and then kill him
and then kill him and then just spin
around and force push and kill and slice
his lightsaber and the gloved hand and
it's green and a bare hand one gloved
hand and i think i know who this is
there's only one person it could be
show me your face it's got to be almost
there die it's luke's guy walker
[Music]
well that was one of the most satisfying
fan games ever but uh like most chasms
it's being immediately followed by guilt
and shame maybe i should rewind it watch
again and let my proper dark side drive
all right here we go why did they stop
why indeed are you telling me the droids
are force sensitive now and can tell a
jedis on board allowing an infant to
watch a violent show also allowing an
infant to watch tv far too closely
that's how you develop poor vision
return of the red eye seriously those
dim holes have their backs to you why
would you wait for this jedi to come out
and do all the heavy lifting when you
have a distinct advantage to take these
droids out sorry i can't buy into that
he can do all this [ __ ] with a big old
robe on no matter how badass it may be
think about it in every jedi fight scene
the first thing they do is drop the robe
even ahsoka did it earlier in the season
and she's definitely a jedi are you a
jedi i'd remove all the sins from this
entire season if luke's response was
something like does a jedi [ __ ] in the
woods i mean
why can't amanda go with the jedi i mean
this is the way right
can't they just stay together with
creepy flesh puppet luke
i'll just point out that grogs wasn't
interested in going with luke until the
sudden convenient r2 electronics showed
up to distract him from his emotions
john favreau can simply not contain his
lust for promotional post-credit
sequences damn it finnick just walked
right over to that trap door and even if
they haven't replaced the rancor that's
still not an optimal spot to stand as
bobo well knows boba the hutt
suck
suck months back i was told we couldn't
have beanies in the store for reasons
they didn't match our sand and stone
color palette i didn't tell anyone at
the time but i was so upset i made a
pack of the demigod in exchange for
beanies i would tattoo i want a
hippolytus for christmas on my ass
anywho good news beanies are now
available in the merc store click the
store link in our description or at
cinemasynth.com
scotty put the ship's faces on stun
you want to know what else i saw i
watched jane die
it's terrible i'm gonna have permanent
hearing damage let me see it i
don't
bargain
easy there little one
you'll be talking through the window of
a back to tank all right easy
save it for the imps
oh yeah just like it nobody backing down
nothing if we had shown half that spine
to the empire we would have never lost
our planet sorry you see what i mean i
just get carried away no no
go sleep go sleep go to sleep
where is this going
this is where it's going all up in here
megatron
do you heal
looking
found someone you have i would say